can we keep playing the okay good we
turn it up a little bit so it's more
pump up okay here we go okay we got to
find the beat think we got clap to the
beat all right okay that's pretty good
guys sorry we're gonna hurt it damn so
good please stop okay stop the music
okay cool can you put on the
presentation thank you he'll be about
the most pump up thing that ever happens
in enterprise software so the rest is
sort of downhill from here so thank you
for that intro that well-rehearsed intro
thank you confirming the facts as you're
saying them
very good so I'm Aaron Levie CEO and
co-founder of box welcome to this
edition of how to build an enterprise
software company that's my understanding
this is the course that you're taking
right is that correct
No okay so here's here's my job today I
my job is to try and convince you that
everybody else who speaks throughout
this sort of whole class is wrong and
that you actually want to build an
enterprise software company and so
hopefully we'll be able to kind of work
through this and you'll have a good
sense of why it's super cool to be in
the enterprise and why a lot of this
sort of perceptions of you know going
into the whole consumer space where it's
you know so much fun and everything why
that's wrong and what you want to do
enterprise software who wants to build
an enterprise software company good all
right thank you very much hopefully
we'll do a vote at the end and we'll
hopefully that will not have shrunk so
that's that's really actually the only
goal I have at this point so well we're
gonna talk about three things today the
first is the quick background and kind
of history of box because when we
started the company we didn't know that
we wanted to do enterprise software and
so I want to kind of get through a
little bit about why we decided to go
after the enterprise and what we do
today and then I'm gonna talk a little
about what are the major kind of factors
that have changed in enterprise software
that make it possible to do a start-up
today in this category and then finally
we'll talk a little about some some
patterns that you can kind of exploit
and some ways to recognize and ways to
actually go and build an enterprise
software company yourself and that's
that's hopefully there'll be some
practical useful advice just as a
forewarning my voice is I've been
speaking a lot of past couple days so
hopefully we'll all be able to get to
that
third part of the device and actually
able to talk so we'll see how we make it
but I'm gonna be downing a lot of water
so I apologize for that so um so billing
for the enterprise this is what we're
gonna talk about so just quick kind of
high-level stats of a box
we have about 240,000 businesses that
use the product through over 27 million
users that have brought box into their
organization and use it as individuals
and there's we're in about 99% of the
the fortune 500 unfortunately at last 1%
is really just Microsoft and they don't
seem to want to they don't seem to want
to buy from us so I'm we have to we have
to work on that a little bit but
certainly you know decent mass scale a
lot of users that have brought box into
enterprise environments these are some
of the the large organizations that are
that are using the product so a very
wide range of industries everything from
manufacturing and consumer products to
companies like General Electric yeah
Stanford Healthcare actually uses the
product for collaboration within the the
hospital environment and some of the
research but between healthcare media
manufacturing these are the sort of
range of industries that that we serve
so questions how do we get here because
we didn't really start the company to
try and go build an enterprise software
company even though that is how things
ended up happening so when we started
the product so we've launched the
company in 2005 we got the idea actually
in college back in 2004 and so was
anybody using the internet back in 2004
okay great so so basically I didn't know
if if Millennials use the Internet so
I'm back then sorry okay no more age
jokes
alright here's a point so back in 2004
you might remember that there wasn't a
lot to do on the internet it's actually
kind of boring right this is before
Facebook this is certainly before
snapchat so not a lot of things that you
could go to you couldn't send people
15-second messages and photos that
disappeared because you didn't even have
a phone to send them photos so um so in
the internet in 2004 there wasn't a lot
going on this was basically the internet
looked like I'm sort of a barren
deserted landscape and this was the
Internet and just to clarify the happy
camels Google and the sad camels Yahoo
and that was that was effectively this
was the internet this is accurate this
is the Internet in 2004 Yahoo is done a
lot better since then but but back in
the middle 2000s there certainly trying
to find their way and Google was sort of
you know kind of taking over the world
but this was the entire this was the
extent of the world so what we noticed
in 2004 in college was that it was for
some reason and this isn't so much the
case today but back in 2004 it was like
really hard to share files and as simple
of an idea as that is now you go back 10
years and and it was either really
expensive or is really hard to move data
through different corporate networks so
I I had an internship at the time and
and then the internship most of my job
using data was actually just to to copy
you know print it out pages and then put
them in cabinets that's all so that's
what you do it as an intern and if
you're not as a computer science student
so so it's like really really good at
copying paper and unfortunately not a
skill that has really been useful today
but it was really hard to share files
and then in classroom environments
you're constantly working with lots of
other people and it was also hard to
share files where I went to USC and USC
gave you 50 megabytes of online storage
space in your email account 50 megabytes
so you basically store about one file
and and then it would auto delete every
six months so so basically I don't know
who is running IT at the time but they
did certainly didn't buy hard drives so
there was just like really really hard
to store and share files and so we said
well why don't we make it really easy to
store and share files from anywhere and
so we got this idea for at the time was
called box.net
and the what we noticed was there were a
bunch of factors that had changed in the
software world the first was that the
cost of storage was sort of dropping
dramatically so in our business
basically every year or two
you can double the amount of data and
storage that goes into a hard drive so
what become what was unethical two or
three years ago all of a sudden becomes
feasible because the cost of computing
the cost of storage has dropped
um we had more powerful browsers and
networks so Firefox was just emerging
people were using the much faster
internet in both their homes and the
classroom and then people had more
locations that they wanted to store and
share information from and so we had
these sort of three factors that all of
a sudden were emerging and I'm gonna I'm
gonna so pull these factors back later
when I want to give some kind of
tactical advice but but sort of the
first point to remember is always sort
of look for these changing technology
factors because any market that has a
significant change in the underlying
either raw materials or enabling factors
is an environment that's about to change
in a very significant way and so we were
very fortunate that that basically the
need for data in the cloud was was
growing in in an importance and the cost
and the feasibility of doing it was also
improving rapidly and so we decided to
put together this really quick version
of box we launched it as box.net
and the idea was let's make it really
easy to share files and it turned out
that the idea clicked we we got angel
funding from this guy named Mark Cuban
and and this was before shark tank but
it was very similar and so we got this
funding and we decided that okay this is
gonna be super exciting we are going to
drop out of college we're gonna move to
the Bay Area and it's gonna be totally
awesome and and when you know when you
drop out of college anybody drop out of
college yet okay good
stay in school so when you when you drop
out of college like everyone sort of
pictures that it's just gonna be you
know incredible like Bill Gates dropped
out of college it'll be like Bill Gates
or or Michael Dell dropped out of
college and it'll be you know super
exciting like Michael Dell or Steve Jobs
dropped out of college so this is what
people imagine but nobody ever remembers
that this guy dropped out of college
also and and so it's not really a
guarantee obviously that that it's going
to be successful but but it's it's what
you do and actually funny if I don't
even know if this guy dropped out of
college but um it just sort of looks
like he had to but
I apologize if anybody's related to me
it's just a funny picture on the
internet so um so basically we decided
we would drop out of college we moved up
to you first Berkeley and then we moved
to Palo Alto a little bit thereafter and
we decided that that we were gonna open
up the product for free we got hundreds
of thousands of people that would sign
up for the product every single month so
we had a free version of the product
called the if you're going to went to
box.net you got a free one gigabyte of
file storage space which was again quite
quite a bit back in 2006 at this point
but we were getting so many users and we
were trying to figure out to do and what
we ran into was a common problem that
really any startup runs into but was
really pronounced by our business model
which was that for consumers we had
built a very robust a very comprehensive
product and for enterprises we had
actually built two sort of insignificant
of a product so for consumers what we
were running into was we had all these
features that you could pay for but a
lot of the consumers didn't need all of
those features and for enterprises we
didn't really have enough security and
we didn't have enough capabilities
around how enterprises wanted to use
their data so we basically had more
functionality than what a consumer
wanted unless they Leonard Enterprise
won and so we found ourselves at this
juncture and we found ourselves
basically in this in this period where
it's very difficult to figure out what
we wanted to go do with the business so
we had to make a choice right and so we
were at this path where there were
basically we just had to choose where a
juncture where we had to choose which
path to go down and this was back in
early mid 2006 up to late 2006 so I was
I think 23 the time the co-founder was
was 22 our founding team was was even
younger was we'd all dropped out of
college and so what we back back in 2006
2007 we imagined you know these two
paths and and sort of the worlds were
very very different like when you do a
consumer startup it's basically just
lots of fun and you know there's you
have parties all the time and it's just
super exciting and then in the
enterprise you basically are battle
just large incumbents it's a fairly
thankless you know model because you
know people just generally hate
enterprise software so that was sort of
how we imagined that the two paths was
was we had to choose you know one of
these two worlds and and so we looked at
that and we said okay well consumer
looks really fun Enterprise looks really
hard and there's a lot of competition at
the same time in the consumer space you
are always fighting this issue of how do
you monetize how do you how do you
actually get people to pay for products
and in the consumer space there's really
only two sort of business models that
you can do you can have people pay for
your application or you can provide
advertising on the application and so
just to give you a little bit of
perspective this these are today's
numbers just to give you a little bit
sensitive the scale difference in the
consumer world there's about thirty five
billion dollars spent on mobile apps
every year pretty big number right the
thirty five billion dollars that's
that's a lot of money being spent on
mobile apps today in for advertising the
global digital advertising market is a
hundred and thirty five billion dollars
so you know basically combined most
consumer companies are going after if
you're not doing e-commerce going after
about a hundred and seventy billion
dollars of either sort of purchasing
power on applications or global
advertising around these kinds of
services so big numbers lot of
opportunity there however in the
enterprise there's actually three point
seven trillion dollars spent on
enterprise IT every single year so these
are the servers the infrastructure the
software the networking the services all
of that stack of technology equates to a
few trillion dollars spent every single
year
and and so what we realized was okay
there's a pretty wide Delta between
these two markets we are gonna be
fighting over trying to get consumers to
pay a few dollars a month and Google and
Microsoft and Apple will probably try
and and make this product be free over
time and there were sort of rumors that
Google Drive was coming out and these
kind of products that eventually happen
we're going to come out but in the
enterprise it's not so much about true
that that they are trying to always save
money on i.t they're actually trying to
increase productivity they're trying to
get higher performance from their
businesses so the
value equation is very different right
in a consumer we have a limited amount
of money that we want to actually you
know make sure that we can serve for as
few things as possible that we're going
to spend in the enterprise it's a little
bit of a different shift where you're
trying to think about actually what can
we get out of technology and how how
much value is that for me so so that was
a really important data point however
the problem was that enterprise software
was really really unsexy right so again
very competitive very difficult to build
a business it wasn't something that
really you you should've shot out of bed
in the morning and said okay I'm super
excited to build an enterprise software
company and the reason for that is
actually was actually pretty
straightforward at the time the the way
that you built software was very slow so
you've got to be very slow because
you're you couldn't break anything for
customers the sales process was very
slow because customers take a long time
to purchase technology so I think
everyone's sort of used to this concept
that you know usually when you try and
sell on a price offer no company can
take up to a couple years for them to
actually just buy the software and then
it can take a couple more years from
them for them to even implement the
technology in the first place so a lot
of companies are around for a few years
without having their technology even
used in the enterprise that felt like
like a huge problem and not like
something we wanted to be a part of um
the technology itself is fairly complex
so the user experience I don't know how
many people have had to use most
enterprise software but it's generally
really complicated you you you find
yourself asking why in god's name did a
designer sort of put 47 buttons on the
page and you just can't even understand
it and the reason is something we'll get
into in a second but basically there's
just no love or care for the design and
the user experience the software is just
really complex and then finally if that
wasn't bad enough all of a sudden you
had to think about how do you actually
sell the software and for anybody who
loves the power of the internet this
notion of having a sort of sales
intermediary to get to your customer
seemed like really unappealing like
you're gonna have to go hire a bunch of
people that are gonna be everywhere in
the country and they're gonna be the
only interface you have to your customer
you're gonna have to hire these guys
named Chuck and it chucks gonna roll in
with a brief
and he's going to just try and sell
lotsa enterprise software to the
customer just so we're clear this is
what Chuck looks like and and that was
the the the sales process that you that
in the enterprise that you at least
imagine in her head and I mean Chuck
looks like a happy guy but but he's
still in an intermediary to getting your
software and we were saying well why
can't we take the power of the internet
and actually get our technology out to
people directly why why should we have
to go through this sales intermediary as
we as we scaled the business now I'll
get into in a minute why we were wrong
about about the sales process but this
was the sort of fear that we had at the
time and then if that wasn't hard enough
we had investors in 2007 saying
basically there's no way you're gonna
make it in the enterprise you basically
are again a founding team of early
twenty year olds you don't have anybody
on your team that has been in the
enterprise the Microsoft and Google and
all these things are not Google but
Microsoft EMC Oracle IBM these companies
are going to stomp on you and it's gonna
be very very hard to actually succeed
and to be fair they were right on a
number of areas right so we were a very
inexperienced team this is this was a
you know stage weird is still early in
our careers my co-founder for instance
looked like he was 13 years old so I'm
just not really just to be clear on this
what he looked like so so it it sort of
made sense right this is this is him as
our CFO at I think this is him at 29 but
it looked like we were gonna go run off
with the money and go to Disneyland so
so I totally can appreciate why they
didn't think we would be able to pull it
off I can't imagine giving him money so
so basically we we decided okay well we
still have to go do it we have to just
give this our best shot we're going to
take the sort of scale the consumer
experience the DNA of our company we're
going to see if we can bring this into
the enterprise and then we were very
fortunate we're actually we had an
investor who was equally early in his
career and made a bet on us because sort
of with the belief that there was
something fundamentally changing what
the enterprise that we would be able to
take advantage of and so we decided that
if we're gonna do the enterprise we're
going to go after the
prai's that we would have to play by a
very different set of rules so what
about the complexity of software can
change in this new era what about the
fact that the sales process is very slow
can change in this new area era how do
we move and go directly to the user into
the customer as opposed to having this
very sort of indirect process of getting
our technology out there how do we build
in design for that user as opposed to
just for the sale and sort of for the
RFP process that a customer is going to
go through and so we looked at all of
the factors that were true of the
enterprise we said we're gonna do maybe
not in all cases the opposite but we're
gonna find what has changed about the
technology world where we can take
advantage of that shift and build a
better and a newer enterprise software
company and so that was the decision
that we embarked on this is the path we
embarked on about eight years ago and
that is why we've been focused on the
enterprise and so today again we have
about 240,000 businesses that use the
product and the reason is we we
architected the the business model we
architected the software we architected
the solution to work in sort of one
specific version of the world and it
turned out that that version ended up
being the the sort of the one that that
happened and and I'll go into a little
bit about what has changed about the
world that we sort of built our company
around and what I would highly recommend
you if you're building an enterprise
software company make sure to to orient
your technology and solution around so
so that was sort of why we made the
decision kind of how we started to take
on the problem now I talk to like to
talk a little bit about what has changed
about the enterprise that makes it sort
of so possible to enter it today better
and more seamlessly than ever before so
everything about the enterprise and then
by definition the software that
Enterprise uses has changed just in the
past five years this is probably the
most magical time if there could have
ever been a magical time to build an
enterprise software company now it's
absolutely that time just in terms of
how much change is is going on within
organizations so let's just go through a
couple of these things so the first is
that most
application categories are moving to the
cloud and the big difference is this
idea that that if you were going to
start a customer relationship management
software company or a business
intelligence software company or even a
content management company 10-15 years
ago
you basically had to go have your
technology be implemented in every
single customer location no matter how
many customers you sold to no matter
what regions they're in every single
customer had to put that in their data
center that was the flaw with on-premise
computing was you were repeating all of
this work you were you were creating so
much redundancy and it was it was then
slowing down the entire process of
delivering and building software for the
enterprise and then all the sudden the
cloud came around things like
salesforce.com
things like Amazon Web Services that
basically said why is it that every
customer that wants to just implement a
couple servers has to go procure the
servers put them in their data center
put all the security all the networking
around those servers and then and then
six months later they go live and then a
developer can use them in the
organization or same thing with an
application the Amazon said why does
that make any sense
today when we could just put together
thousands tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of servers and make them
available on demand and you just use
what you want when you need that and
that was that's obviously the definition
of cloud computing what is happening
though is finally CIOs and large
enterprises are taking advantage of this
so it's it seems obvious for everyone in
this room because you would never build
a company by buying your own servers you
would start it on Amazon or or Google or
Azure or whatever but to an enterprise
there are decades literally decades of
investment in infrastructure that now
has to move to the cloud and so that's
obviously a massive shift that is
finally happening
we are moving to a world of cheaper
low-cost on-demand computing from the
world of expensive computing the benefit
to building a start-up is that customers
don't have the same kind of friction
when they're gonna go adopt new
technology right as soon as the
computing is so much cheaper it becomes
easier to adopt new solutions which
means that their barrier for having a
conversation their barrier for
introducing you them into
to their enterprise is a lot lower which
creates a massive opportunity for
startups we're going from a world of
customized software to really
standardized platforms so it used to be
that you had to build custom
integrations and all of the custom
experiences on top of the software
itself and now customers are realizing
that actually they want open platforms
and they can customize that the layer
above the the product it used to be that
when you were building an enterprise
software company you could only really
sell to the top five or ten thousand
companies in the world because only
those companies had beware with all the
talent the infrastructure and the budget
to deploy your technology into the
enterprise today literally a two-person
company can sign up for box as well as
we work with General Electric which has
over three hundred thousand employees so
the fact that you can now serve a small
business anywhere in the world as well
as some of the largest companies on the
planet mean that there's much larger
markets that you can go after which
makes it obviously even a better
economical economic proposition to to go
after the enterprise the platform's
themselves are becoming more global so
our customers were international
literally within the first couple of
weeks of starting the company it would
have been usually if you had done
enterprise software the traditional way
that would have taken years to actually
be able to go international and then
finally and probably the most profound
shift of all is that because of mobile
devices you know iPhones iPads tablets
Android devices the IT model of the
enterprise has become a lot more user
led and that's fundamentally important
because in an IT led world incumbents
generally win because they have the
existing relationship with the IT
organization with the CIO with the
spending power within that company in a
user led model users are bringing in
their own technology they're bringing in
it on the sales team they're bringing it
in in the marketing team they're
bringing it in in finance and you can
build software then around the user
which means that they can bring the
technology in then you can sell to the
enterprise when they want to have better
control better security better
scalability so you still have the same
business model as a traditional
enterprise software company but the way
to get into the company is now through
the end user okay so those are
qualitative factors changes just occur
quantitative factor changes there's over
nearly two billion smartphones on the
planet that changes every single IT
model on the planet because it used to
be ten years ago if you were managing
technology for an enterprise
you just had to manage the computers and
the network that were inside of your
building but now with it with billions
of mobile phones you fundamentally have
to be able to manage the network and the
computing that is going to be anywhere
at any time on any network and that
creates a massive opportunity for
software companies because no incumbent
has built the technology stack sorry for
my voice breaking again so no incumbent
has built a technology stack that powers
this next generation of of work and how
enterprises are using their data so that
creates a massive startup opportunity
mmm there's nearly three billion people
online what that means is that every
single enterprise is equally changing
how they're going to get their own
products to their customers which means
that every industry changes and so there
are really only two what times there are
only two moments of opportunity where a
technology revolution will happen in the
enterprise the first is if the raw
materials change so cost of computing
goes down and then it's better to
centralize and then let people use it on
demand the second major change is that
the very customers that these
enterprises have to go after need new
experiences of working with those
enterprises products let me give you an
example if you know if when you go off
campus you probably do something like
uber or lyft as an example
the-the-the if you were in the
transportation business if you're in the
shipping business if you're in the
logistic business uber represents a
massive change to your industry so you
can't just let Oberer exist and do its
own thing without understanding what are
the implications of uber what are the
implications of instacart what are the
implications of lyft to my business
model and so in a world where
enterprises are dealing with that kind
of change they're gonna need new
technology to help them evolve their
business models and how they adapt to
this disruption and so in every industry
and this is why it's an amazing time to
even build vertical software companies
for industries right now every single
industry is going through a major
business model and technology oriented
disruption which means that they're
gonna need technology from startups to
help them work through this I'll give
you a couple examples so in the retail
industry there's this notion of sort of
omni-channel or multi-channel commerce
you're going to shop online you're gonna
shop on your phone you're gonna shop in
a store and you want things to be
delivered to you as well so most of the
incumbent technology and the retail
industry doesn't power multi-channel
commerce no nobody is prepared for what
does it mean when consumers want to go
actually buy goods at any time from
anywhere with better information and
better intelligence so every retailer in
the world is going to need a new
technology stack to power their retail
experiences in the healthcare space
every single healthcare institution is
trying to find ways of building more
personalized experiences more predictive
experiences they want to have medicine
be be adapted to the individual as the
business model of healthcare changes
from being about charging for the
surgery charging for the checkup and
instead really where the customer pays
for wellness and staying healthy then
all of a sudden every healthcare
institution needs better technology to
deliver healthcare experiences they're
gonna want to deliver telemedicine
they're gonna want to deliver healthcare
in more regional locations as opposed to
just in the monolithic Hospital
environment there's going to be new use
cases around how do our electronic
health records get connected to one
another so doctors can make far better
decisions all of these things are going
to require new enterprise software to
power these businesses in these
industries in the media space as an
example you know you have a world where
an industry is going from really linear
programming so whether that's television
whether that's music or whether that's
movies this sort of very linear supply
chain oriented business model where a
film gets made it goes to the movie
theater for three months and then
afterwards it goes to iTunes and these
other platforms to a world where people
want experiences on demand so that's
going to change how distribution works
on the scale of three billion people
that are on the internet and again no
media company has a platform
that is going to be able to actually
power how content and data and
information moves through the system at
scale we were just I was just in LA
yesterday meeting with a media company
that has basically done predictive
analytics to find their potential movie
goers in the population of 3 billion
Internet users they want to be hyper
targeted on how do they get to the very
the sort of specific 30 million people
that are fans of different kinds of film
types and so all of a sudden you have a
movie company that actually needs big
data and they need business intelligence
and they need marketing automation to go
power how they're going to go market and
distribute their movie so again totally
unpredictable mashup of two industries
coming together we're all new kinds of
software is going to be necessary so
every industry is going through some
form of this change you can pick any
industry you want and take and sort of
zoom into it and say what are the
underlying technology factors that are
going to change the business model of
this industry in the next couple of
years and then there's going to need to
be software that goes and powers those
experiences cool are we all on the same
page great I just need to drink water so
if you could say something that'd be
great can we also edit out my water
drinking so it doesn't make it look like
just have some weird water problem okay
cool I mean think about the future of
water
who's gonna power that right you're
gonna need that's gonna need software
I'm sure so
so basically every company in the world
we we think of we you know the good
fortune of being in Palo Alto being a
Stanford is is we're so hyper focused on
technology and we think of the
technology industry as an industry but
in reality what's happening is every
company every industry is going to have
a technology component of what they do
there you won't be able to survive in
the future enterprises will not be able
to survive in the future if they don't
get good at technology if they don't
have a competency in leveraging data and
using these new tools but they're gonna
be they're gonna do that through working
with what we consider the technology
industry as opposed to everybody
building out these pockets of expertise
themselves so there's gonna be a lot of
partnership over the next five to ten
years where companies are going to need
to use technology to work smarter to
work faster they're gonna need to do
this more securely and this is gonna
change not only how individuals work in
these environments but ultimately change
the business models of these companies
so that was chapter two of this that's
all the things that have changed now
some practical advice we're we're to
help to kind of help you get started and
to be fair most of this advice is
looking through the sort of lens of
retrospect which means that that this is
not always how things happen but I can
look back in time and say these are the
things that led certain things to be
true so it's hard to be super
deterministic about building a company
and and you might not have all of these
things totally figured out but these
this will give you a sense of some of
the patterns to recognize and
opportunities to exploit as you're
building or thinking about building an
enterprise software company so the first
is spot technology disruptions and this
is going to be true whether you're
building consumer or enterprise the rest
are more enterprise oriented but this is
just fundamentally this is just
fundamental to entrepreneurship if
you're gonna build a tech company so you
have to look for new enabling
technologies or major major trends like
fundamental trends that create a wide
gap between how sort of things have been
done and how they can be done and so
looking back in time it at our business
the the gap was basically
the storage was getting cheaper internet
was getting faster browsers were getting
better
yet we're still sharing files this is
very complicated
very esoteric very slow and cumbersome
means so anytime where the Delta between
what is possible and how things work
today is that its widest that is an
opportunity to go build new technology
to go solve a problem and so as you're
looking at the enterprise the question
is what about the cost of computing
dropping so rapidly changes what
enterprises can do with their data what
does it change about what you can do
from a business model standpoint what
was impossible because of either
economic feasibility or technical
feasibility 10 or 15 years ago that now
all of a sudden is is possible and a fun
thing you can do sometime is if you go
look at articles from like the 1990s or
even the 1980s business articles about
technology the wall we're really doing
is repeating a lot of the technologies
that were tried 10 20 30 years ago it's
just it was too expensive it was too
unusable and we didn't have the enabling
technologies to make it possible so you
can kind of see this pattern emerge
constantly we're something that was
impossible five or ten years ago all of
a sudden becomes very practical so I'll
give you an example there's a company
called planned grid does anybody know
what plain grid does okay cool are you
in the construction industry you are oh
my god what does that even mean
construction holy crap that's great okay
thank you so it's basically planned grid
playing grid is a it's a mobile
application that lets you manage
construction projects lets you get
access to your blueprints lets you
manage all of the data around a
construction process and what this team
realized was that four billion dollars I
believe are spent every year printing
out blueprints and making all of the
prints and updates to those blueprints
anytime there's a change and then ask
the ripple and cascade through a very
wide network of of contractors and
construction people every time that
there's even just one slight my new
change and they realize that you know
with the iPad all of a sudden we have
the perfect form factor to be able to
load up blueprints and load up content
and this is something that could ripple
through the construction industry which
isn't necessarily a notoriously known
for kind of high technology except for
on the design side how could they build
technology that would make the data
access data collaboration problem really
really seamless and easy to do in a in a
very you know traditional industry that
hasn't quite changed for for a while so
it was a sort of perfect sort of
discovery of a technology change in a
market and figuring out how do those two
things converge and then this team built
a a great startup out of it that is um
that is doing incredibly well and in
totally taking over the construction
industry as proven by this individual
thank you so the next thing is in the
enterprise you want it start
intentionally small what I mean by that
is you want to find and this is again
true of a lot of companies but even more
true in enterprise in a user led
paradigm you want to find the wedge that
is sort of the very natural place where
you can create a product that will slip
in between the gaps of other existing
products but is something that you think
over time expands to become a more
important part of the enterprise
architecture so what you want to start
to do is say we're going to take this
sliver of a problem we're going to
totally make the user experience on that
incredible we're going to either change
the business model we're going to create
new technology that makes this
previously difficult problem really
really simple and it
might feel small at first maybe you're
going after small businesses and then
you're gonna move up market maybe you're
starting at just a sliver of the use
case and then you're gonna expand out
but you intentionally start small
because you will not be able to compete
with an incumbent because the incumbent
is going to always go for the full
solution so you have to find what are
the gaps in the full solution that are
significant enough where a customer is
going to want to solve the problem with
the discrete technology but that over
time you're going to be able to expand
again either to larger customers or to
more use cases over time a great example
is then payroll
so the zenpayroll started by a Stanford
Graduate er saying for graduates couple
of years ago basically discovered that
the payroll process in small businesses
is an incredibly complicated and
annoying and cumbersome process and
that's because we use the same vendors
that we've been using for decades to do
that and they weren't sort of digitally
oriented you didn't get your your sort
of you know you didn't get your payments
as a receipt over email is very
complicated you didn't really get to see
graphs of of your salaries
there was no real good data around this
and then they said we're just gonna take
off the slice that is most painful to
startups around hiring people and around
paying people which is just that payroll
management process we're gonna plug into
a lot of existing infrastructure but
we're gonna make it dead simple to go do
this and now they're able to move both
upmarket over time as well as deliver
new services over time and what happens
is the incumbents in this market
initially look at something like
zenpayroll and they say well that's
small it's only for small businesses
it's not gonna be very powerful but
that's just the start because as they
get that wedge and as they fit into the
market they're gonna be able to expand
again over time build out more services
and more capabilities but they found
just the exact right opening to build a
new company and have that emerge the
next is you really want to find
asymmetries you want to find my god okay
so can we do some like auto like some
tuning of my voice later
so at least it'll sound like real good
like I'm doing rap okay
hey you so so you want to be able to you
want to do things that incumbents can't
or won't do
because either the economics don't make
sense for them or the economics are so
different or so unusual or because
technically they can't I'll give you two
examples so if you're gonna build
software today for the enterprise that
goes after an incumbent category that
has more of a suite oriented approach
then what you want to go do is you want
to build technology that's going to be
platform agnostic because what suite
players will do is they want everything
to be integrated with it with itself and
that there's more value with that
vertical integration but you want to go
after a different access which is you
want your technology to work across all
of the platforms so that way you can
work with so many different kinds of
customers and you can be an ally to so
many different kinds of platforms which
a traditional incumbent is not able to
do so that's something that is usually
technically infeasible because of
because of how either something has been
architected or because it's a
fundamental component of business model
to not do that as the incumbent but the
other thing is try and do things that
are economically infeasible you can look
at the cost structure of an incumbent
company and discover where are they not
going to be able to drop their prices
because that business model is
fundamental to the existence of the
company or where can you find ways of
monetizing the customer that are unusual
unusual or unique that no one has
discovered before and thus is really not
practical for anyone else to do
that's a company called zenefits where
they have a HR management software
company that helps you as a small
start-up manage all your benefits all of
your HR information and instead of
charging the startup which might not
value that software at the stage that
they're at they realize that they could
get commission from the insurance
companies
and that basically pays for the ability
to use their software so the customer
itself is not paying for zenefits the
zenefits platform is being paid for by
the insurance company and they've thus
invented a business model that that no
other software company has been able to
think of or attack and they're equally
going and disrupting a category that
hasn't seen a lot of innovation
previously which is the the health and
benefit space within small businesses
the next is you want to find they're
really crazy but but sort of still
somewhat reasonable outliers within the
customer ecosystem so you need to find
the customers that are sort of at the
edge of their business or at their
business model or of their industry and
find the unique characteristics about
those customers and leverage them as
your early adopters so Paul Graham has a
great article where he talks about
living in the future and building for
what is missing when you're living in
the future so that's a sort of easy way
to spot trends and patterns about
disruption that's playing out the same
is true in the workplace if you find
customers that are working in the future
you will be able to work with them to
find what is missing when you're working
in the future and how do we build
technology that supports all these new
use cases that are going to emerge this
is a company called sky catch which does
enterprise drones and on the first that
seems very kind of weird but in the
construction space in farming in oil and
gas they're using drones now for data
capture and the ability to do modeling
of of different environments and so this
company is able to find all of the
companies that are at the bleeding edge
of their industry what is unique or new
about how those organizations operate
and they built and worked with with a
lot of those early adopters to establish
their platform which is again really one
of the first enterprise drone companies
so the idea is go look at your market
find the customers are at the bleeding
edge of the market who use technology to
get ahead and that use technology for
performance advantages and then go work
with them to discover how how your
product can evolve two minutes okay
good okay so the the next one is banana
there's a part two in five minutes for
now or not is that not the case okay so
listen to your customers but don't
always build exactly what they're
telling you this is a really key
distinction around building enterprise
software your customers are going to
have a large number of requests your job
is to distill those requests down into
the ultimate product that does not mean
that you're going to build exactly what
they tell you to build it is your job to
listen to their problems but
actually translate those into what is
going to build the best and simplest
solution to those problems it's really
your job and that Palantir does this as
an example with very very complex issues
and then they distill those down into
simple solutions for very very complex
problems that the customer otherwise
would not have known how to ask for you
want to modularize not customize so
build a platform as opposed to building
all of the custom technology and custom
vertical experiences directly into the
software itself make sure that you
really think about openness and api's as
a way of delivering vertical or custom
experiences don't build that directly
into the product focus on the user
always so again the magical thing about
building an enterprise software company
right now is you can keep consumer DNA
at the center of the product that will
always mean that adoption is easier your
product is a much higher chance of going
viral it becomes easier to sell into the
organization so always make sure you
bring consumer DNA into the product
development process and your product
should sell itself but that does not
mean you don't need salespeople so this
is a really important distinction
leverage everything about the internet
leverage everything about users to get
to your customers but you still will
likely need sales as a way to help your
customers navigate your product help
your customers navigate the competitive
landscape and the ecosystem so you're
going to want consultative very very
sort of domain oriented sales
individuals that are going to be able to
be helpful in your customer being
deployed and enabled in these
organizations but don't make that be a
substitute do not make that be a
handicap for not building for building a
great product so you fundamentally have
to keep the product at the center of
that company called Mixpanel
comes in through the developer and then
over time is able to sell to that
organization with the more inside sales
web process will also read these three
books so so crossing the chasm
innovators dilemma and behind the cloud
these three combined especially if you
read if you binge and you just read them
all you'll you'll definitely come out
the other end with a massive software
company
and so in closing today right now when
you leave this room is an amazing time
to go start an enterprise software
company so I wish you the best of luck
and of course if it doesn't work we are
hiring so so and then the only other
caveat is please do not compete with me
because I have a lot of competition
already so ideally either come work for
us or build your own company so thank
you very much
[Applause]
you